madness
crazy that's rude did you just put your
hand up as if you've done that no i was
going to say that
[Laughter]
so knowing that do you think that men
should date women with lower body
counts how would that impact it though
because what if it's just one guy and
the guy was slapping the brakes off him
was doing a madness look at it
i'm asking you
um
no i don't think that really has a
bearing you don't think body count
matters no i think body counts matters
but i don't think that has a bearing of
whether she's going to think about it
because she's going to think about it
she's not satisfied so it's more about
are you throwing it down like you should
yeah but the more people she slept with
the less likely
like if she said
no if she slept with 50 dudes you think
you're going to be the best out of 50
dudes but i think it's all she hopes so
she has to hold back
in my previous life had a 50. i'd
experience
i'd experience slinging my weedy around
and doing my nightstands but it's not
actually good sex and it doesn't make
good at sex
now you probably have the most enjoyable
sex when it's with one person i'd say
so it all depends it really it comes
down to you
you have to be super accountable and
look at yourself and just like do i have
magic fingers or am i mr flashes like am
i doing what i need to do yeah really
intriguing
that's a very blue pill ideology that's
like men need to step up no i think well
i suppose if you can say it's pretty
pill but it's just like yeah the reality
is if me as a man
i can't make my woman be able to think
about just me yeah then well but why
wouldn't you pick a girl that you don't
have to deal with that baggage oh yeah
then 100 yeah 100 but what i'm saying is
even if you're saying that baggage but
say even if she slept with patrol like
what if
the size is just different and you can't
continue yeah but then then it comes to
accountability if i pick the wrong one
like you need to pick the one for you
and if if she's not satisfied by me
there's signs you know when a girl wants
to sleep with you and knows if you're
the one or not
so really it comes down to
why am i experiencing this squeezing
this baby i i think that most girls can
pull one over on a guy i think most guys
think they're smarter than they are in
my opinion like i think only the only
people that really know is her close
friends where you fall yeah i i agree
with you on that one yeah because i've
seen it where like i've seen a girl
like a guy
or so what somewhat like a guy
and then
when i've seen her with another guy that
she really likes her behavior her
mannerisms she won't even come up and
say hi to
guy friends that she she will like act
accordingly and i'm like
okay so this is what it looks like when
she really likes someone and that's when
i it changed the game for me like a red
pill moment
because even
i i think most girls can trick a guy
into like thinking
yeah yeah
like and i always tell this story so
there was a girl that i knew in college
i might have you might have heard this
already
but so there's a girl i knew in college
and basically her freshman year at
college she dated the bad boy right
senior year she's dating the nice guy
man bought her a house
he bought a house yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah well like just beautiful vibes
i mean i just think it was like the next
step they've been dating a little bit
because remember this is like three four
years later right
so
you know she'd been dating him for a
minute no ring no no just house
i didn't i didn't i mean they're 21 i
don't know i just know
she and him
moved into a house and
i'm at a party my senior year of college
and i see her walk out of the bathroom
with the guy from freshman year it
happens
and it was crazy because an hour later
the new guy shows up
i feel bad for him and so that's why
i i say the girl the guy that she
complains about like that's the one that
got her
there's the saying after god fear eve
because women can actually just
lie to you like that i don't i can't
believe
he wouldn't notice anything i mean so at
all like any of that behavior no i think
i think women cheat more effectively
see if amanda mandela cheated mandem are
sloppy sloppy but you see a woman the
way she'll cheat yeah you won't even
believe like it's
ever possible that's scary
what's that okay and jess have you ever
seen a girl cheat yeah what's the
craziest thing you've seen someone cheat
hmm
i'm trying to think
what is the what is the craziest um
oh i had a friend who
was dating a dude
and she had another dude asking to
fly her out and fly her out to another
state go hang out with him dinner
everything and she was contemplating it
and i'm like if you're in this
relationship with the dude she's like i
think i'm gonna do it and i was like
okay
all right that's that's your choice you
know it's bad like you're in a
relationship with a dude but you're
gonna get flown out by this guy she's
like oh we're not going to do anything i
was like all right
i'm just going to go have a dinner and
then go back to an airbnb and chill
she's like i think i'm going to do it i
was like
okay
have you guys ever seen a girl cheat
no not really no
loads of times
like loads of times like with you
[Laughter]
you know you know what the the funniest
thing is guys will tell me they'll be
like the i didn't realize how how bad
women were until i was the guy she
cheated with yeah because like mandom
used to turn it into a game like growing
up it should be like oh like you know
the whole mr stu your girl like stuff
like that yeah
i remember a person who remained
nameless
they were out
and then
they secured the girl on the night out
or the lady i should say
and gone to the car
she's grogging him off doing the throat
go business in the car
um
the husband's called it's just like i'll
pick you up
she's finished off
the guy and then she's got and picked up
by a matey wow she drove home she's
happy satisfied she was happy this is
crazy
oh my god women are
that's interesting do you think men
cheat as bad
not as bad
because men are sloppy like if your
man's cheating you probably know that's
bad deep down you probably know that
he's cheating yeah
like women always have a hunch exactly i
would agree with that yeah would you
would you guys be willing to share a guy
if if he had everything you wanted he
loved you
but just now and then he would step out
just arrives
look at it look at it
me and jess are on a two-for-one special
get it while you can yes sister wives
would you actually do that
no
no
you might i might okay why tell me why i
don't
i think monogamy is very hard i think
long term man and women so would you
look an open relationship are you
talking about on his end
um
it would have to be both oh it would
have to be oh
yeah it would have to be so we still
love
could you still
because a lot a man we've had the
conversation before a man can love a
woman and throws willie around and fall
into vagina from time to time but a lot
of women they can't do that so would you
could you say that you can still love
the guy you're with and still be open in
a relationship in my mind
i think after a certain amount of years
5 10 maybe 20 years yes
in the beginning early phases i don't
think
i could because that possessive like
need to claim is there but i think
eventually i